foreign
welcome Jane the last time you joined us
so good to see you as always
the last time you joined us on Ted women
Jane I was thinking about that this
morning you were in the nation's capital
Washington DC and you were leading the
weekly protests fire drills Fridays fire
drill Fridays in partnership with the
Greenpeace International
we got arrested it made headlines and
certainly all of the Civil Disobedience
actions brought attention to the crisis
and I understand that you are restarting
fire drills Fridays in December what are
your goals and expectations
well
our goal with fire drill Fridays was and
continues to be uh to move people from
concern about the climate crisis to
action about the climate crisis and
we've been successful we're coming back
on December 2nd to Washington D.C for
our first live in-person rally which
will address the outcome of the midterm
elections and we'll talk about uh what
climate activism needs to look like in
2023 but you know Pat we never stopped
the weekly rallies when covet hit we
went online with fire drill Fridays and
last week we had our 11 millionth viewer
it's it's working people who had never
taken action before have been trained by
Greenpeace U.S to write and call and
visit their representatives they follow
up on our calls to action they
participate in getting out the vote and
volunteering with candidates for those
in other countries you should know we
have a very critical midterm elections
coming up in a couple of weeks
um anyway so our people are becoming
activists that green and fire drill
Fridays by the way has become part of
Greenpeace so we're very honored by that
well there's no question that it had
impact and it's really encouraging to
know that you're bringing back the
actions and convening us again and I'll
certainly try and be there Jane uh to
participate uh in fire drill Fridays and
you mentioned the elections very
important elections happening in the
United States in November and you have
taken some additional action another
priority by creating what we call a
political action committee a Pac explain
your expectations and and why you see
this as a necessary action
well after Decades of marching and
protesting and petitioning in Civil
Disobedience we still are not getting
the kind of climate legislation that is
absolutely critical
um
what we need to do is reduce fossil fuel
emissions and uh you know recently in
the U.S we got the inflation reduction
act which puts a lot of money and
Renewables like electric vehicles and
the bread and pants solar panels and so
forth but too much legislation that's
that would have been important has
failed because both Republicans and
Democrats take money from the fossil
fuel industry and I know this is a huge
problem in all oil and gas producing
countries
um and so earlier this year the uh we
launched the Jane Fonda climate pack
with a unique goal of electing climate
Champions to office not just top
governmental office but state and local
offices which turned out to be really
really important you know we
we have to break the Stranglehold that
the fossil fuel industry has on our
government not just here in North
America but globally and that's why
we're moving climate activism into the
Electoral Arena which is
it's kind of unique because we focus
down ballot and because we're trying to
change the narrative about fossil fuels
you know everybody talks about wind
turbines and solar panels and electric
vehicles
um but that's not enough
and my pack is only endorsing candidates
who have signed a pledge to not take
money from fossil fuel industry and
who've publicly stood up and showed
courage in the face of of the industry
and um
not afraid of holding them accountable
and those were the that was the criteria
on which you selected the candidates
I've I've also noticed some of them uh
maybe most of them are women seeing
women taking those Frontline positions
women of color
very often they're the first the first
woman the first Latina
the first person under 30 they're
they're really breaking a lot of
boundaries and they're they're so brave
they I was just in Texas and it's filled
me with hope that'll last me for years
well I want to come back to how you keep
that hope alive Jane because
some it's easy to look at the fact that
climate is not a partisan issue and yet
as you said leaders on both sides of the
aisle are still taking the money that's
leading to the carbon emissions uh
challenge
why really do you have a better
understanding now and can you share it
of why we have such slow progress on
addressing this urgent Global crisis
well I think a lot of it has to do with
the fact that the fossil fuel industry
is is is embedded in our government
people on both sides of the aisles are
taking money and so they don't speak out
against the fossil fuel industry they
only talk about the green Alternatives
and that's important but not talking
about fossil fuels is is like trying to
bail out a sinking boat without plugging
the hole you know
um
but there's been progress because more
and more people do understand that
that it is fossil fuels that are driving
burning of fossil fuels it's driving the
the climate crisis and and and this is
this is really really important the
science is very clear we have seven
years to cut our fossil fuel emissions
in half in order to keep our our global
warming no higher than 1.5 degrees
Celsius higher than it was before the
Industrial Revolution which is when we
started to burn fossil fuels
um so I mean I think there has been
progress locally especially in States
and in in in cities they've made
progress to reduce their carbon
footprint it's just that more needs to
be done urgently and the reason that I'm
talking about this on an international
Forum like like like you've provided is
because I I think that a lot of
countries I'm thinking of Nigeria for
example have the same problems that the
United States does they produce oil and
that we need to be thinking more about
taking the climate activism into the
Electoral Arena you know recruit
candidates and then train them and teach
them about climate science and then get
them to run for office and make sure
they win this is this is really what the
strategy is now
and and you're so right Jane that is a
strategy that could be exported to every
country because in every country there
are in most every country there are
elections and and people can make a
difference by the candidates they
support and encourage to run
yeah
I I do uh think often of your activism
and how you've sustained it especially
when it comes to this issue which
sometimes feels intractable although we
know it isn't but when you hear
scientists say seven years we're this
far away we haven't done this we must do
that it's easy to lose hope it's easy to
let fear that we can't do it replace the
Hope necessary uh to ignite action so
what what gives you hope
well as I said we we have elections here
in the U.S in less than two weeks and
I've been traveling the country
supporting amazing candidates that my
climate pack is endorsing you know we
don't have enough money yet we're a new
pack to play in the Senate Arena or the
governorship arena which uh you know
they cost a lot of money those races but
um the down ballot races you know the
ones in the state legislatures and
County Supervisors and Attorneys General
things like that are so important and
every dollar that goes to those down
ballot races means a lot for for
instance in Texas the Railroad
Commission oddly is in charge of
regulating and overseeing the oil and
gas industry you know it
historically
um it it was supposed to regulate the
railroad but then when Texas became uh
you know the massive oil and gas
producer they switched the
responsibilities of the Railroad
Commission to oil and gas but they
didn't change the name so a lot of
people don't even know what the railroad
condition does and historically all the
Commissioners there's three of them
they've worked for the very industry
that they're supposed to regulate right
which means they do nothing
um I don't know if people that are
watching uh know about this or read
about it in the paper but two years ago
when there was an extreme freeze and the
electric generators failed to produce
enough power power to keep the lights on
and the heat running and I I talked to
neighbors who were found frozen to death
in their own living rooms and none of it
needed to happen extreme weather had
shut down the grid before the Railroad
Commission had been warned to weatherize
the grid and nothing was done and still
the grid hasn't been weatherized and so
it remains very vulnerable to another
disaster so my pack
is endorsing just as one example a young
Progressive Democrat happens to be very
handsome named Luke Warford He's 33
years old he's not afraid to hold the
oil and gas industry accountable he's
not to build a career but to really make
a difference and if he's elected
it's going to change how the commission
does its job and believe me Texans and
the planet will be safer not only has he
pledged to weatherize the grid he's
going to enforce regulations against
flaring which is a practice of burning
excess gas that releases methane into
the atmosphere and as you all probably
know methane is the most damaging
greenhouse gas and Texas releases more
of it than any other state so this can
all change if this young guy is elected
to office and then in in Harris County
Texas Harris county is enormous and it
is Ground Zero for the climate crisis in
North America and this woman immigrated
with her family from Colombia she was
elected as the top Harris County
Executive judge Linda Hidalgo the first
female and the first Latina to ever hold
the that particular incredibly important
office and she became a citizen of the
U.S in 23rd 13 and she got elected in
2018 you know nobody took her seriously
you know oh that her opponent didn't
even bother to campaign but in the four
years since she was elected to office
she has blown everybody's Mind by how
much she's accomplished she's holding
the fossil fuel industry accountable
she's made it easier to vote she stopped
a highway going through Houston she's
changed the way the county Works she
controls a four billion dollar budget
and has a robust climate plan to to to
change
how Harris County deals with fossil
fuels you know she she believes that the
energy capital of the world can also
become the renewable energy capital of
the world and I've seen in the last
month how a big difference in my new
climate pack is having on on down ballot
races like Luke's and Lena's and this is
what Thrills me this is what gives me
hope I believe the most important thing
that I've ever done is creating this
pack and it's what I'm going to continue
to do till I die
the giant that those kind of stories are
what we need to hear I mean how
inspiring is that that one single
individual has made that difference in
their community and I want to come back
to that
it's as though Vanessa nakante ran for
office you know what I mean what would
that look like and I'm putting that out
there because maybe she could consider
doing that you know I I hope Vanessa is
listening and if she isn't we'll make
sure that she gets this message
Jane we have a question from Kat
um who was joining us from the tedx
women in Vail Colorado and and you may
have done this just now but I'm sure
there are others she asked could you
describe what are your most joyful
moments as a climate activist
well frankly I got back from Texas
yesterday and I'm my body is still
humming with the thrill
of of working with these young people
you know it happened two weeks ago in
New Mexico with a young woman who's the
public land commissioner also a Latina
woman and in Michigan with the attorney
general Dana nessel they are so brave
and they so understand that fossil fuels
is what's killing us and they're not
afraid and they're to stand up to the to
the big corporations and it just makes
me I can see the future when I'm with
them that's what gives me uh hope
and and joy
we we hear from a lot of people though
who you know will say back to a story
like that well that person's an elected
official or they've already taken a
leadership position and often you'll
hear individuals say I'm not I just
don't know what I can do as an
individual in a community how do you
respond to that right well that's a
really really important question the
truth is there's limited impact that we
can have alone and there is infinite
impact we can have together so the most
important thing that any of us can do
besides voting is to join with others to
to share our passions so so that we can
have a bigger impact you know join an
organization join a climate group get
your community or your church group
active on climate and you know the great
thing about doing this work with others
is in addition to having a bigger impact
it's more fun it's more rewarding we
make new friends
but
to answer your friend you know many
people's questions
when it comes to individual choices a
recent study has shown that there is one
big impact of making climate-friendly
lifestyle choices things like you know
don't use single-use Plastics anymore
you know ride a bike instead of driving
a car Etc
it increases your credibility as an
advocate for the kind of bigger and
Bolder change that's needed so you know
for example
Greta tunberg sailed across the ocean
this had no impact on actual carbon
emissions and climate change but it had
an impact on people taking her message
more seriously and that's a really
interesting finding so what follows then
is that the way to increase the impact
of our individual choices is to be sure
that they're visible
so that if you replace your old gas
powered water heater with an electric
heat pump for example or you install
solar panels or you use a real a
reusable water bottle make it visible
tell your neighbors post pictures on
social media not at a you don't have to
be self-righteous or braggy about it but
in an inviting way hey folks here's an
idea you know make it visible
and make it personal as Mary Robinson I
was always encourages us do something
personal every day uh that moves us
forward to a better time there's another
question Jane it comes from Dallas Texas
so I think people in Texas are paying
attention to the stories you've just
shared she says it it's so important to
be able to identify climate activists
the ones that will really fight for
legislation to combat the climate crisis
so how do we meaning we at large in a
community no and back candidates who
we're who are going to actually Fight
For Change Is there certain criteria
that you are using and that would stand
out for anyone who claims to fight for
green legislation
yeah number one
do they take money from the fossil fuel
industry that is a No-No because that
means that they're not free to really
stand up to the fossil fuel industry and
here in the United States in North
America we have What's called the fossil
fuel pledge where many many many
politicians and candidates sign a pledge
saying that that they won't take money
from these big corporations
um and then the other thing that that we
look for has the candidate shown Courage
by standing up publicly in some way have
they opposed an oil pipeline have they
opposed something that might pollute the
waterways in your town or city
um
doing something publicly shows that you
have real courage and and you're willing
to to stand up and fight
and looking for the candidates who do
that and then working for them
supporting them
um and encouraging them to run and that
can as you have reminded us happen
anywhere we have another question this
one comes from New Jersey so many young
people have now taken the stand to
support climate initiatives and at times
we see their activism is motivated by
fear about the future anger towards the
older Generations who did so little to
present this moment from happening what
message do you give to Young activists
like Vanessa
and others around the world to keep them
in the streets demanding change
join them in the streets
that's what I did
I went to DC and got arrested five times
with fire drill Fridays and we were
there for four months getting arrested
every Friday
um we started out with 13 people getting
arrested and by the time we end there
was a little less than a thousand I mean
it it really grew
um
words don't matter show with your body
put your body on the line and show them
that you are willing to join them in the
streets we need huge numbers come and
join us on December 2nd in Washington DC
I plan to be there
Jane we we keep hearing a lot about the
seven year timeline and we know we
that's the timeline we have to reduce
carbon emissions to where they need to
be by 2030 to get to Net Zero by 2050.
in order to do whatever is necessary we
have to imagine there's a better time
some people have actually a a wonderful
indigenous leader actually proposed the
question Jade Begay she said one of our
best times are ahead
and I frankly had never thought of that
we think so much of the worst feature
we're rushing and hurtling towards how
do you envision what might be our future
seven years from now
well it's going to take a while because
of all the heat that's already been
baked in because fossil fuel Executives
lied to us about what their emissions
were doing you know which they knew for
four decades but when I think of how the
world will be Generations from now if we
do what's science says we have to do I
I see healthier people because the air
we breathe and the water we drink and
the food we eat will be clean and safe
nature will begin to return species on
the brink of Extinction will rebound
coral reefs and dense forests and
snow-capped mountains that we can see
from a distance will bring joy to us
once again and and our little
species Homo sapiens will feel happier
and and less anxious because and I hope
that along with confronting the climate
crisis we will have confronted economic
inequality and misogyny and racism
because you know the climate crisis has
happened because of a mindset of
arrogance greed and and and hierarchy
you know some things like white men are
more important they're on the top of the
hierarchy they matter more than people
of color or women or the natural world
but there would be no climate crisis
without racism there would be no climate
crisis without patriarchy so it's going
to be a beautiful future if we make it
so and we are the last generation that
can do so
and that is an awesome responsibility
and this is an all Hands-On deck moment
so let's all join together
it's an awesome responsibility and an
awesome opportunity
for us to do this together
I just have to ask you Jane Before We
Say Goodbye because so many people have
written about their concerns of knowing
that you are battling cancer and we just
want to know you look fantastic but how
is your health
well for the week when I have chemo it
you know it it's um
I don't feel like my old self but after
that I'm I feel good in fact I feel
better than ever because you know that
cancer was in me and it was kind of
eating away at me and I was tired all
the time and I'm not anymore I I Got
Strong just in time for the midterm
elections I'm I'm uh I appreciate people
so I was hoping my hair would fall out
or I was going to shave my head to
climate emergency on this new real
estate that I was going to reclaim well
cancer activists don't like to have
issues mixed together so I I didn't want
to do it if the cancer Community
wouldn't stand with me but
um it's good I'm I'm thank you for
thinking of me and I'm just fine thank
you
with it's just so um great to know that
you are well and you are continuing this
work and as Jane reminds me and I'm just
going to quote her on this activism is
the antidote to aging and Jane Fonda is
a perfect example of that working not
just for her but for the world thank you
so much Jane for joining us today
thank you for having me Pat it's great
to see you